je trouve ça ouvre quand même toujours
pas réussi a inventé le world par ponce
ou plutôt décevantes et un petit peu
comme quand tu pensais que le père noël
n'existait et quatre ans qu'existe pas
tu t'en doutes est m'aider quand même
déçu et du coup c'est devenu une sorte
de fantasme
c'est un truc qu'on essaie d'atteindre
alors qu'est-ce qu'il faut l'atteindre
est-ce que l'hoverboard doit exister
parce que papa papa
marty et doc sont censés revenir
aujourd'hui et contrairement à ce
qu'avance la science fiction
on n'a toujours pas d'eau board pourtant
tu as tellement d'entreprises qui ont
essayé jean présentera sa passe à gaza
et a même des entreprises qui n'ont pas
du tout essayé mais qui ont quand même
appelé saola world
en fait c'est devenu un objectif pour
l'humanité et au tellement blasé départ
réussi à le faire
on en vient à faire des fausses pubs
s'te plaît est ce que le plus gros échec
c'est pas quand l'objet de mentir à toi
m
mais je comprends tu vois c'est
important d'avoir un objectif même à
l'échelle de l'humanité
enfin surtout à l'échelle de l'humanité
c'est bon pour le progrès le progrès
c'est une récente ça en plus ça date de
descartes pascal galilée genre avant les
gens croyants la répétition et genre
tout ce qui était nouveau s'étaient vus
comme des gagnants
tu ne verras ya toujours des gens qui
pensent comme ça aujourd'hui enfin quand
je parle de progrès je parle de la
transformation qui nous amène à un état
a dû plus on reparle de quantité ou
alors à du mieux on parle de qualité
clairement dans retour vers le futur ii
on va nous présenter par exemple des
films en hologramme ce qui a priori et
du progrès et du pepsi perfect qui a
priori ne l'est pas alors il faut aussi
garder en tête que le progrès n'est pas
nécessairement positif par exemple des
fois on va vouloir régler un truc un
problème avec le progrès a qu'en fait on
va juste le dépasser c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet de rebond
par exemple avec l'explosion de
l'ordinateur du digital on pensait que
sa lettre la fin de paquets alors qu'en
fait la consommation de papier à
augmenter parce que les gens les
particuliers s'équipent en dans tout et
le progress un truc globalement on
cherche tous en fait ça vient d'une idée
un peu naïve qui dit que bah si on est
malheureuse parce qu'on vit dans la
misère et que si on vivait dans
l'abondance on serait plus haut et pour
plein de penseurs de hugo à marx le
malheur du monde et venez de la misère
et du coup pas la solution c'était la
technique
globalement à part dan bull d'ariane qui
a l'air très heureux et quand on
reparlera une prochaine fois
cette idée c'est un type n importe quoi
même si j'avoue je prends pas le
malheureux avec un ipod qu'un lecteur cd
men avec leurs avoirs entre est on allé
trop loin
alors on a cru qu'on allait tacler un
truc comme la gravité aussi facilement
mais je vous dirais
parfois je me dis que c'est peut-être
par ammann déjà parce que ça leur donne
de la valeur à l'innovation
quand tu vois le nombre de trucs qui ont
été prévus pour retrouvera le futur et
réaliser ces couches et tong sang top
tout le temps pas ce genre les gens
pensent que genre ça tombe du ciel c'est
normal les niveaux qui dit une phrase
super cool là dessus d'ailleurs on a
bien plus louer les hommes occupés à
faire croire que nous étions heureux que
les hommes occupés à faire que nous le
fusion en réalité quelle bizarrerie dans
nos jugements en fait ça ne donne pas de
la valeur qu'à l'innovation
sarah donne de la valeur à la science
quoi rien n'est acquis t les
scientifiques c'est pas des chasseurs
cueilleurs qui partent et qui reviennent
avec une innovation et en plus en plus
le fait de ne pas avoir réussi à faire
leur board
ça va donner un truc pour nous surpasser
si t'as pas d'objectif et que t'as pas
de but c'est très difficile d'évaluer
comment tu avances essais montrent très
facile de balancer du tout et c'est
super intéressant que dans un film sur
le voyage temporel on routine quand même
l'hoverboard parce que les deux sont
très liés pour les deux en fait c'est un
truc sur lequel on fantasme pour défier
votre condition mortelle alors qu'en
fait c'est une atteignant je crois après
comme je dis il ya plein de trucs on a
réussi à réaliser par exemple
finalement les arènes avec une pizza
déshydraté transformant pizza normal et
nous on fait mieux on imprime des pizzas
percement pas à quoi ton fait une
fixette sur l'autre importe alors que on
a les skate sont déjà très bien et en
plus si le world sort à 90% des gens qui
seront pas en faire ça n'a aucun sens en
fait 6 en 1 c'est parce qu'on est
ambitieux saissac 97 overboard et c'est
pourquoi c'est la seule chose qu'on
retient de ce film en termes de progrès
le mât était ambitieuse elle aura
toujours besoin de nous leurs banques
ce sera peut-être pas de l'hoverboard
cocktail mais ce sera un objet qui nous
fait rêver qui est difficilement
réalisable et qui nous rappelle du coup
tout le terrain qui nous restent à
conquérir
alors je veux bien que l'hoverboard
existe la pâte russie et d'ici là il va
falloir qu'on trouve un objectif tout
aussi cool qui est du coup moins
réalisable mais plus réalisable qu'une
de lorraine qui voyagent en passer
parce que ça c'est choquant
j'espère que t'as kiffé mais c'est
abonnés pour ne rater aucun épisode et à
balancer tes réflexions en commentaire
parce que ça c'était juste la vienne
l'ars a donnés à la science un défi
c'est bien la seule à pouvoir encore le
faire vous envoie du love est le messie